لدي 10 أحفاد حتى الآن ، خمسة من هؤلاء
في هذه المرحلة يذهبون إلى نفس المدرسة الخاصة ، حيث
يقوم الآباء جميعًا بإسقاط
أطفالهم أمام المدرسة في
خط السيارة كل يوم ، يقول الأطفال دائمًا
إنني أحب مدرستنا ولكننا سنفعل ذلك.
أحب أن أكون قادرًا على الحصول على حافلة مدرسية
عندما اشتريناها ، وضعنا بعض اللافتات
على الجانب حتى يكون هناك
الجد السريع ، وبعد ذلك لن
يكون لدي أحزمة أمان مضافة من المقاعد ،
يبدو لي أنه
شيء مُرضٍ  أن تكون قادرًا على اصطحاب الأحفاد
إلى المدرسة في الصباح
، ما عليك سوى توصيلهم والقيام بذلك في حافلة ، نعم سنصعد
إلى حديقة الحيوانات ونقوم بأشياء
مختلفة بدلاً من العام ، ولكن الأمر يتعلق في
المقام الأول بقضاء بضع
دقائق مع  كل صباح
في الحافلة المدرسية